the left-hander eduardo rodriguez
looking for his third win
all smiles he's as loosey-goosey as it
gets i said it right away he is relaxed
as ever he he's been relaxed since he
came to the big leagues how about this
he's thrown at least five innings now
and 30 consecutive starts the red sox in
those games have gone 24 and 6.
simeon hitting 182 with power though
former oakland a
it's a little bound or to short early
test here for xander one man gone crowd
would like a punch out
of bo buchet
yes
got it 95 he dotted the inside corner
little paint piece inside corner nicely
done
pair of shoes from mr machete fastball
was back the movement back the pitch
swinging a hard shot to short on one hop
sander underhands to second for the
force that retires the side
blue jays elected to push ryu back to
this series against the first place
boston red sox it also gives him an
extra day of rest and ryu has been a
little bit sharper in his career
after he's had a few extra days in
between stars this will be a challenge
for hyunjin ryu and vice versa be a
challenge for them as well ground ball
to short and buchette will throw him out
one down
of the regular season
one one curveball hit in the air to
right center field can of corn as they
say tabby for randall grichik two down
first here is
jd martinez first pitch swinging and hit
to right center field pretty deep
grichik back and he makes the catch
just before brushing up against the
fence in the triangle a nice play and
the red sox go in order
remember they had a double header on
sunday too and now bogart sends one to
left field look out it's over the head
of goriel as he misjudges it looked like
he had a beat on it but
he misjudged it and it sails over him
and winding up at second on the play is
bogart's catcher christian vasquez is
the batter
first pitch swinging pops it up and
immediately slams the bat down on the
plate in frustration as gretchen comes
in in shallow center to make the catch
one two and a great changeup is popped
up right side guerrero the first baseman
will make the play right beside simeon
and two down and the blue jays with
three infielders to the left of second
base
1-1 change-up popped up into right field
it took a while for biggio to find it
twilight time into boston but he's there
to make the catch
2-1
hammer nice play there by bobby dalbeck
who's made a few of those lately
perfect placement line drive got a man
there nice play bobby d the ball's two
strikes the pitch swinging a pop-up back
at first long run for dolbeck out onto
the grass and bobby is there to make the
play
made the pitch in there for strike three
got him looking simeon complaining for a
moment but it's a one two three again
for eduardo and ryu about as good as
anybody two at getting the ball on the
ground and wouldn't this be the ideal
situation to get a ground ball trying to
turn two there it is down to third
espinal the second one simeon to first
for two
we're going to the top of the fourth
note score boba chet
bo buchette leads off the fourth hits
one high and deep to left field headed
for the monster and way gone
right on over the seats and out of the
ballpark park a booming home run for
boba's shack to give the blue jays a one
to nothing lead
this time it's almost like he was
looking for that cutter that stayed out
over the plate and he extends through
watch the extension right there as he
stands right through it takes it out of
here for his fifth home run already
had 22 in 2009
that sucked for a base hit back-to-back
singles
first two men have reached here in the
fourth inning xander started his season
one for 12. since then he's banning 467.
slowing down his tempo here with base
runners
high fly ball
that one deep to left up there it goes
it is gone
that's a three-run shot first home run
of the season for xander
and the sucks grab the lead 3-1
his first ride of the season here's
bobby dalbeck
high fly ball that one driven to center
racing back richie he can't get it it
bounces around in the triangle another
run will score
gonzalez across there goes bobby into
third with a triple bobby d the deepest
part of the ballpark home runs triples
double singles wearing it out
but what a great night only the solo
home run yes
set him down another strikeout give him
five they go in order
new clubs will meet 19 times
turns on that rockets that one for the
wall
and that will reach right at the base of
the 310 mark affair ball
and it'll be another hit for christian
arroyo who's two for three in this one
oh beautiful thing 3-2 change-up down
stayed on it just enough that'll bring
up christian vasquez for the third time
2-2 is popped in the air to center field
this should do it grichik is there and
that will retire the side a long inning
for ryu
first pitch and a fly ball to center
kk hernandez with a one-handed grab he's
had a number of those tonight one pitch
yes
struck him out
92 on the gun there he fans simeon for
the second time and they're two gone
yeah back to back to back fastballs it
gets them 3-2 and it's just too tempting
so descend up vladimir guerrero jr has
walked and flight out
bounding ball right at xander bogarts
and that will end the inning eddie's
going to start this seventh inning
whether he finishes it or not is another
issue randall gretchek leading off the
seventh for the blue jays 4-1 red sox
and grichik lifts a fly ball to left
field high and deep and gone and he
sends it out of here for a second home
run of the season doesn't overswing a
nice soft swing and he's rewarded with a
home run
the hook is out should have been six
plus innings giving up three hits two
runs
and here it comes to buchet
swing gonna miss 95
to blow bachet away
one of the key moments tonight 4-2
boston
ninth inning
red sox four blue jays two and toronto
making this interesting right down to
the end here comes guriel
yes
96 he caught him looking strike three
two down it'll be up to kevin biggio
biggio is oh for three
[Applause]
95 and he pops this one up into left
field verdugo there
and in to make the catch and the red sox
win it they take game one from toronto
4-2 the final score and water rodriguez
picks up the win
boy is matt barnes one confident closer
it is his fastball is talking and he's
throwing it